on passe tout de suite à notre second
débat vous le savez en séance publique
on passe régulièrement au crible les
propositions des candidats ou des
candidates avec cette question et des
9000 est courte
et aujourd'hui c'est donc une
proposition signée valérie pécresse que
l'on analyse la candidate du parti à
l'air les républicains proposent de
modifier la constitution pour y inscrire
des quotas migratoires flora sauvage si
elle est élue présidente de la
république
valérie pécresse veut mettre en place
des quotas migratoires
la candidate veut faire voter une loi
constitutionnelle pour fixer des quotas
par pays qui serait fixé chaque année
par le parlement
chez dit stopper l'immigration
incontrôlée j'ai dit système de quotas
quotas migratoires ont choisi qui en
accueille pourquoi et parce que c'est
plus efficace et c'est plus courageux
mais la marge de manoeuvre pour
instaurer ces quotas est limité en
matière de droit d'asile aucun quota ne
peut s'appliquer puisque ce droit est
garanti par la constitution
quant au regroupement familial que
valérie pécresse aimerait restreindre il
est protégé par le principe du droit à
mener une vie familiale normale reste
donc l'immigration économique en réalité
la seule immigration qui peut réellement
être visés ces migrations qu'on dit
économique c'est-à-dire une immigration
qui est une émigration qui déjà est en
grande partie une migration qualifier
parce qu'évidemment il ya une
immigration illégale qui ensuite fait
l'objet d'une régularisation mais par
définition celle là les gens sont déjà
sur le territoire elle pas réellement
faire l'objet d'une régulation via des
quotas concrètement pour mettre en place
ces quotas migratoires il est nécessaire
de réformer la constitution
le projet de loi doit être voté à
l'identique par les deux chambres
ensuite le chef de l'état pourra soit
organisé un référendum soit faire voter
la révision constitutionnelle par le
congrès
mais quentin migratoires il est neuf ou
idées courtes c'est le thème de notre
débat j'accueille florence porter dit
bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes
vice-président de la région
ile-de-france porte parole de valérie
pécresse tanière la chaux bonsoir ça
aussi docteur en droit européen ses
soeurs la cour nationale du droit
d'asile et puis vous êtes membre du
collectif les surligneurs qui analyse
justement les promesses des candidats
sous l'angle de leur faisabilité
juridique vous êtes les surligneurs
partenaires de public sénat dans cette
campagne présidentielle john's arabe
bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes essayiste
auteur de retrouver la république c'est
aux éditions du cherche midi et merci de
m'avoir dédicacer votre livre à
l'instant laetitia cru pas éditorialiste
politique est évidemment rester à mes
côtés alors idées neuves aux idées
courtes on l'a pas choisi simplement
pour cette promesse ou cette proposition
de valérie pécresse a on passe au crible
régulièrement les propositions des
candidats et donc je fais régulièrement
un premier tour de table une réponse
assez courte à la question du débat puis
ensuite on aura le temps de détailler il
est vrai vous des cours de florence
portelli vous allez me dire bonnut est
forcément j'avais voulu dire dit lundi
d'autres c'est pas tout à fait une idée
neuve dans le programme de français
fillon nicolas sarkozy avait évoqué sa
existent aussi ailleurs dans d'autres
pays et idées courtes non parce que
c'est pas si simple que ça à mettre en
classe ça pose des questions au niveau
du droit et notamment au niveau du droit
constitutionnel du choix de réforme de
la constitution sans dents parlera
sûrement oui bien sûr à votre avis de
juristes idées nos idées courtes alors
j'aurais tendance aussi à dire ni l'un
ni l'autre parce qu'effectivement il ya
des aspects qui pourrait éventuellement
être mise en place et ça pourrait être
assez assez compliqué mais clairement
c'est une idée qui qui revient
régulièrement et et surtout quel est
l'objectif derrière cette idée parce que
si c'est stopper les flux migratoires il
ya déjà des rapports qui date de 2008
qui ont qui ont déjà mentionné que ça
n'était pas forcément efficace
pour moi c'est une idée courte parce que
c'est là mon avis l'illustration de ce
que la droite républicaine n'a pas
travaillé depuis une dizaine d'années et
qu'on nous ressort les mêmes recettes
depuis un certain nombre de mois alors
c'est peut-être la conséquence de cette
campagne interne très à droite vous avez
dit un mot donc je réserve mon analyse
pour la suite mais là il me semble que
la droite peut mieux faire et que c'est
une idée très courte bon métier ça qui
compte courte également puisque dans
d'autres pays par exemple aux états unis
on a vu que quand on annonçait comme ça
des quotas ça faisait paradoxalement
venir davantage de personnes de migrants
donc ça c'est quand même cc établissent
et établissons des faits sociologiques
donc quand on voit ça on ce n'est pas
que les états unis qui fût ce que ces
indices canadiens ont fait
au canada ça fait aussi
défaut les chercheurs se sont sont
tombés d'accord sur le canada
va rentrer dans le détail thiérache où
peut-être dans quels cas est ce
qu'aujourd'hui je parle pas forcément de
la réforme et ce qui pourrait se mettre
en place mais dans quel cas aujourd'hui
c'est juridiquement
possible ou impossible d'ailleurs de
fixer des quotas d'immigration et hop il
ya des cas dans lequel s'est clairement
impossible il faut les rappeler oui tout
à fait parce que dans la catégorie
d'étrangers ou même d'immigrés en fait
il ya plusieurs réalités derrière et et
alors ça c'est évoqués dans le projet de
valérie pécresse évidemment tous les
demandeurs d'asile réfugiés ne peuvent
pas être soumis à des quotas est la
question des immigrés bien c'est à la
fois les immigrés économiques la
question du des immigrés titre vie
familiale ou regroupement familial que
le regroupement familial aujourd'hui ne
peut pas être concerné par nancy
malgré une réforme constitutionnelle
éventuel c'est impossible parce que il
ya un encadrement européen sur la
question et c'est parce qu'il
constitutionnelle aussi au niveau du
droit alors pourquoi pourquoi ça me
semble possible sur la question du
regroupement familial au niveau du droit
bon en fait pourquoi des jeunes réforme
constitutionnelle parce que c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui on ne peut pas faire
autrement et c'est vrai qu'il ya des
jurisprudence du conseil constitutionnel
qui n'autorise pas cela donc à partir de
la réforme constitutionnelle
pourquoi d'ailleurs allez plutôt de
l'article 89 constitution et pas
d'article 11
je crois que c'est délibéré tran qui
propose l article 11 ça définit un champ
assez strictes de sujets que vous pouvez
soumettre à référendum quand sertic le
89 ça veut dire que vous soumettez votre
projet de loi constitutionnelle au
parlement qui doit voter dans les mêmes
termes sur les deux champs et après vous
choisissez de vote final pour faire
simple facile congrès qu'ils seraient
unis qui vote la majorité des deux tiers
soit c'est un référendum 3/5 pendant
trois ans qu'elle va redonner de dire ça
avant mais on quittera 5e et après donc
sinon c'est un référendum valérie
pécresse irait plutôt d'ailleurs vers un
référendum parce que ça lui donnera
encore plus de puissance peut-être à
tout cela d'ailleurs il n'ya pas que sur
l'immigration qu'elle veut faire ce
projet consensuel c'est aussi sur la
sécurité liée à des jurisprudences
successives du conseil constitue donc ça
c'est le premier point après
deuxièmement en effet c'est par rapport
à la suprématie de la constitution ou la
suprématie des traités est là
très clairement on déjeune conseil
constitionnel ne peut pas être saisi sur
une projet de loi constitutionnelle il
va pas juger de la constitutionnalité de
la constitution pour faire simple après
la question c'est est ce qu'on peut dire
ah bah oui mais attention au nom du
principe enfin du contrôle de
conventionnalité c'est conforme au droit
européen au grand international etc non
par aussi du principe qui existe
aujourd'hui depuis jurisprudence de 2006
mais plus renforcée depuis 15 octobre
2021 le principe d'identité
constitutionnel c'est-à-dire
qu'aujourd'hui quelque part nous conseil
constitutionnel et d'heures sur des
sujets qui sont quand même dit ce sujet
de la migration puisque c'était sur les
transports d'étrangers la décision du 15
octobre 2021 sur la délégation a des
envies tout à fait lever mais comment
définir a rappelé le principe de 2006
c'est à dire il ya des sujets qui
reflète l'identité constitutionnelle de
la france et qui ne saurait être un
sujet qui en gros au droit européen et
alors effectivement c'est intéressant
parce qu'on voit qu'il ya une vraie
stratégie constitutionnel dans ce projet
puisque l'idée c'est d'inscrire à
l'article 2 de la constitution oui la
possibilité de démettre dit je pense que
la droite en tout cas madame pécresse
vous avez droit de pas être d'accord
mais pas au t4 méprisant elle a bien
travaillé ces sujets non mais janot
article 2 de la constitution le drapeau
français est tricolore il est donc il y
à des quotas d'immigration à la fin trop
et on rajouterait ça pourquoi on le fait
pour l'identité consensuelle de la
france
mais moment je disais pas ça pour être
désobligeant c'est un constat j'ai 27
ans a fait au moins quinze ans que la
droite nous dit on va faire des quotas
en 2007 nicolas sarkozy le disait déjà
aussi mais en effet c'est bien de
rappeler on peut ne peut pas limiter ce
qu'on appelle les migrations de droit
d'asile et le regroupement familial sauf
mais peut-être que vous allez nous
l'annoncer sur public sénat ce soir si
valérie pécresse dit qu'elle va retirer
la france de la convention européenne
des droits de l'homme auquel cas ça
irait jusqu'au fond du raisonnement et à
ce qu'on appelle ration l'émision
l'immigration de faveur c'est à dire les
étudiants qui viennent c'est-à-dire
l'immigration économique là on peut
effectivement mettre des quotas mais moi
ce qui me semble intéressant au delà de
la mise en oeuvre c'est la question du
fond quel est le fond politique et
idéologique qui conduit cette droite que
je qualifie aujourd'hui de droite dure
de droite moi je pense que c'est la
ligne eric ciotti en réalité qui a gagné
dans cette élection interne il ya l'idée
premièrement que l'immigration coûterait
plus cher à la france que ce qu'elle ne
rapporte il ya une étude du mois
d'octobre 2020 de l' ocde qui démontre
que à quelques centaines de milliers
d'euros près ça n'est pas vrai
n'oublions pas non plus est un autre
sujet et que valérie pecresse elle veut
limiter là et me l'aide médicale d'état
rappelons qu'éric ciotti voulait tout
simplement la supprimer l'aide médicale
d'état c'est un milliard d'euros sur un
budget de l'état qui ont fait 300
milliards c'est-à-dire 0,3 pour cent du
midi du budget donc il ya bien sûr
symbolique ce sont des mesures et barker
politique ce sont des mesures populistes
parce que le discours le sous texte de
cette mesure c'est un l'immigration
coûte cher et deux nous serions
submergées c'est le discours alors je
reconnais à valérie pécresse le fait
qu'elle ne le dit pas et qu'elle ne
l'expriment pas de la même manière
qu'ils ricciotti vous faille mais le
fond le sous-texte pour moi c'est celui
ci et je ne crois pas que nous
résoudrons la question de l'intégration
la question de la politique migratoire
le présent macron a fait une conférence
de presse tout à l'heure laissez les
accords de dublin qu'il faut revoir
c'est la migration l'échelle européenne
donc moi je pense que c'est une mesure
marqueur politique parce que valérie
pécresse elle doit rattraper des
électeurs de marine le pen et d'eric
zemmour et donc on peut le rester très
limité votre réponse soit bon car déjà
juste un dernier point sur le
regroupement familial la cour européenne
des droits de l'homme parce que quand on
visionne sens et violé la convention
européenne des droits de l'homme on se
retrouve éventuellement si on est
poursuivi enfin quoi européenne des
droits de l'homme je rappelle quand même
qu'ils énormément de jurisprudence
défavorable à la france parce qu'on
s'arrête au stade de la première
instance et français depuis des années
vont rarement interjette rarement appel
quand vous avez un appel c'est un peu
différent et que font certains pays pour
asseoir leur position qui est quand même
un marqueur politique
il envoie systématiquement des remises
de la justice c'est comme cette les
italiens d'heure ils ont eu gain de
cause sur l'histoire des crucifix dans
les écoles que ça aussi que les suisses
ont eu gain de cause sur plein de choses
donc vous savez c'est un peu plus
compliquée et complexe que ça maintenant
j'arrête le débat qu'on voit pas
suffisant des fois c'est dur on a bien
compris donc c'est moi je pense qu'on
peut aussi revenir sur un regroupement
familial après le shifah tout à fait
d'accord avec vous et je trouve ça un
peu condescendant elle a annoncé ça
depuis 2018 c'est un sujet sur lequel
elle travaille et c'est pas une histoire
de coups je suis maire de banlieue je
suis maire à taverny dans le val d'oise
mme g lundi j'avais un conseil des
droits et devoirs des familles que j'ai
instauré je vous assure que c'est pas
qu'un problème c'est aussi un problème
d'intégration c'est un problème sensible
baptisé des uns et des autres d'avoir
déjà le temps d'intégrer ce que j'ai sur
mon territoire et de ne pas pouvoir dont
certains sont mais ici donc ces gens là
ne sont pas les échanges et ça semblait
france je suis entièrement d'accord est
d'ailleurs le projet doit de valérie
pécresse en effet il serait très court
si ça ne s'arrêtait quotas il est très
long il a plusieurs articles il est
aussi d'ailleurs d'assimilation de la
langue française il y a le fait vraiment
lé japon aujourd'hui un nom aujourd'hui
faciliteront le séjour y faut démontrer
l'apprentissage
connaissez pas le français si vous ne
parlez pas bien vous pouvez clame être
naturalisé - dfa c'est pas vrai dans les
faits on est pas si exigeants des
beaucoup plus exigeant par exemple en
allemagne donc non il ya ce problème là
de problèmes aussi de l'appartenance à
une nation aux valeurs républicaines et
la laïcité il projet doit aussi par de
tout ça après moi je trouverais ça
personnellement réducteur je ne serais
peut-être pas sa porte parole si par
exemple elle ne parlait pas aussi
d'éducation et valérie pécresse elle
part d'éducation c'est pour ça que je
suis pas d'accord avec vous c'est pas
une droite rabougri parce qu'à part de
ces sujets là parce que c'est important
parce que c'est le bazar dans nos
banlieues et qu'on en peut plus qu'un
des prince d'intégration et à côté de
cela je suis désolée elle parle aussi de
social avec l'augmentation des salaires
elle parle d'éducation par rapport
justement à ces valeurs communes et au
civisme elle part de beaucoup de sujets
et je pense qu'il ne faut pas là la
rivière même si le rapport est fier de
ça par rapport au regroupement familial
est ce que les aides sociales pourrait
être une variable d'ajustement parce que
il me semble qu'elle a évoqué le fait de
les prestations sociales non
contributive et qu'il faille attendre
cinq ans mais vous savez aujourd'hui
pour déjà un petit peu forcément
d'ailleurs on sent dès aujourd'hui je
vous rappelle quand même un détail le
rsa c'est aussi assujettie à cinq ans de
résidence sur le territoire ça n'a
jamais figurent des personnes âgées
c'est quelque chose alors pour le
regroupement familial parce qu'elle peut
pas mettre de quotas sur ce magicien de
d'expliquer pourquoi tout à l'heure je
pense qu'on est là quand est-ce que
comment comment et ben il va justement
ajusté avec les aides sociales
concrètement ces affaires je comprends
pas votre question la lada position
délire et on habitait le grincement
fallait aller simple regrouper limitée
regroupant famille c'est aussi avec
instauration de quotas bon on a dit je
l'expliquais tout à l'heure j'ai
expliqué pourquoi mon avis vous pouvez
même aller devant la cour européenne des
droits de l'homme avec ça en poussant
les procédures jusqu'au bout bon alors
je vous excusez moi c'est un vrai sujet
mais on vous a entendu cet effet auprès
des cours je ne dis pas le contraire je
rappelle que c'était votre argument je
propose qu'on reprenne un extrait de la
conférence de presse des macros parce
que finalement le premier thème dont il
a parlé dans cette conférence de presse
était justement l'immigration la
question de l'espace schengen des flux
migratoires je vous propose d'entendre
un extrait de cette conférence de presse
sur la redéfinition des règles de
schengen
vous initieront sous cette présidence
une réforme de l'espace schengen autour
de deux priorités
la première ce sera la mise en place
d'un pilotage politique de schengen
comme nous l'avons fait pour
la zone euro
nous avons mis en place une organisation
politique de celle ci avec des réunions
régulières au niveau des ministres des
finances
nous souhaitons installer une
organisation et un pilotage politique de
cet espace schengen à travers des
réunions régulières des ministres en
charge de ces questions deuxièmement
souhaitons porter la création d'un
mécanisme de soutien d'urgence aux
frontières en cas de crise voilà pour la
déclaration du présent et plus que ce
qui est intéressant les ti siècle passé
que dans ce mandat dans ce quinquennat
d' emmanuel macron la question des des
quotas migratoires avait déjà été
évoqué à l'époque c'était edouard
philippe qui était le premier ministre
oui c'est edouard philippe mais c'était
emmanuel macron qu'il avait évoquées qui
avait lancé le sujet rappelez-vous dans
sa lettre aux français c'était à la
sortie de la crise avec les gilet jaune
et à la veille de lancer son grand débat
national et donc c'était sensé balisés
si vous voulez 7 cette grande
consultation qui l'a lancé avec les
français rappelez-vous thomas il y avait
les cahiers de doléances dans les
mairies où chacun pourra aller répondre
aux questions du président parce que
c'était pas non plus la grande foire aux
questions il avait posé des questions
très précises emmanuel macron dont celle
ci est alors il ne dit pas quotas dans
sa question puisqu'il dit en matière
d'immigration
une fois nos obligations d'asile remplie
souhaitez vous que nous puissions fixer
des objectifs annuels défini par le
parlement en gros des quotas nego admis
grattoir mais il n'avait pas dit de
cette façon là il avait laissé son
premier ministre et loire philippe
ensuite faire la synthèse en novembre à
l'issue d'un séminaire sur les
migrations écoutez
notre volonté c'est de faire des choix
en matière d'accueil
fixer des objectifs quantitatifs ou des
quotas les deux termes me vont en
matière d'immigration professionnelle
mettre le paquet sur l'intégration par
le travail
bon et effectivement le gouvernement
avait dit avait mis sur la table qu'à
partir de 2020 il y aurait des quotas
d'immigration immigration économie qui
seront débattus chacun par le parlement
un an plus tard les résultats ne sont
pas concluants du tout et emmanuel
macron a dit aujourd'hui qu'il refusait
de revoir la constitution à ce sujet
donc c'est un peu ce statu quo du côté
quand même des manuels macron par
rapport à la volonté politique est
ensuite aux résultats parce qu'entre
temps je pense qu'il ya eu la crise
sanitaire et sa famille un peu sous
cloche ce type de réforme est-ce que
c'est aussi pour ça laurence porte ni
que que vous y allez où il ya des
convictions je
doute pas des conditions de valérie
pécresse mais
voilà est-ce que c'est aussi port en
vous disant c'est un non dit où c'est
une réforme avortée du du quinquennat
macro et donc voilà on se démarque je ne
compte plus les réformes avortées 1 je
cherche encore des réformes doit avorter
donc si vous voulez nous on part du
principe qu'il faut réformer le pays
pèse sur l'immigration alors j'ai
heureusement qu'on parle pas que de ça
et
on considère certains trouveront à tort
et que ça a été un quinquennat avec
extrêmement peu de réformes donc moi je
suis pas étonné du tout par sa prise de
position et des volte-face sur tous les
sujets des retraites le nucléaire à sa
bête l'immigration ça se trouve dans
deux mois il va nous annoncer des quotas
donc
on l'a évoqué tout à l'heure on a évoqué
tout à l'heure que vous c'est vous qui
nous l'avait dit quand qu'en 2008 la
question avait déjà été posée il y avait
une commission la commission mazeaud le
démographe hervé le bras participer à
cette commission il était sur ce plateau
il ya quelques semaines c'était le 14
octobre et voilà ce qu'ils disent est
finalement des résultats de la
commission sur les quotas migratoires
j'ai participé à la demande de sarkozy
il ya dix ans à une commission la
commission mazeaud qui est une question
sarkozy avait demandé l'établissement de
quotas le rapport de cette commission
est disponible à la documentation
française 250 pages on a procédé à un
grand nombre on à la conclusion qu'elle
on peut dire que ma pierre mazeaud
n'était pas un homme de gauche la
conclusion de pierre mazeaud et de
l'ensemble du groupe qui était plutôt je
dirais penchant à droite a été que
c'était impossible au vu des auditions
c'est impossible de définir des besoins
et surtout des besoins géographique mais
vous relire lisez ce rapport je trouve
un peu dommage que au fond le monde
politique et une telle capacité d'oubli
et c'était l'ami matthieu croissandeau
qui qui présentait la preuve le
quantième remplace fait bonne émission
bref juste pour faire la boutade
je redeviens sérieux parce que la
critique elle est rude quand même dans
la dans les propos des revélois grosso
modo à quoi ça sert de recommencer un
medic c'est impossible juridiquement
même dans le rapport on voit qu
inefficace ce serait inefficace il dit
pour lutter contre l'immigration
irrégulière ce qui est un peu l'objectif
j'imagine inefficace pour maîtriser les
flux parce que en fait si on regarde les
chiffres les plus c'est la zil et
l'immigration familiale dans laquelle il
n'est pas possible de mettre des quotas
des titres de titre de séjour sur des
questions économiques
en 2019 par exemple avec 40000 qui était
délivré par rapport à des titres
familiaux ces 80 milles où la demande
d'asile 180000 aussi finalement c'est le
en plus c'est le plus petit nombre 40
mille
titres de séjour délivrés qui pourrait
être strictement concernés donc c'est
que sur ses quarante mille titres par an
qu'on pourrait agir concrètement
juridiquement par des quotas
john rabe sur cette même question le
loup fait d'heureux de ressortir des
tiroirs une réforme qui avait été à
l'époque de nicolas sarkozy jugé
inapplicable mais je j'ai pas envie de
me répéter mais si en 2008 la droite le
disent elle ne l'a pas fait ça montre
bien que depuis elle n'a pas évolué et
que c'est la facilité un certain que
vous me proposez notre forme un peu
différente maimouna 12 articles moi je
veux bien on peut passer la nuit sur les
côtes améliorée que les quotas je reste
un peu mais c'est le cas me
permet juste de vous dire qu'en effet ce
sera un peu court si je veux dire c'est
une addition de proposition d'un
ensemble sinon c'est vrai que c'est un
peu court j'ai pas que c'est l'alpha et
l'oméga de la limitation d'immigrés dans
mais qu'est-ce que vous changé par
rapport à ce qui avait été étudiée en
deux pour que cet article ah non mais là
je vous dis quand même très clairement
je suis désolé ça a été étudié avec des
spécialistes avec des professeurs de
rang constitutionnel avec patrick
stefanini qui a priori quand même il
connaît un certain rayon non pense
sincèrement que c'est possible et aussi
parce qu'il ya une évolution de
jurisprudence du conseil constitutionnel
cette question d'identité
constitutionnel qui est récente d'un
jurisprudence du conseil elle n'est pas
je vous ai sur thomas hugues c'est
beaucoup de juristes le disent elle
n'est pas anodine elle est important
alors on va je demande alexandre
pousseurs de nous rejoindre pour pouvoir
ce qui se fait à l'étranger vous avez
commencé à évoquer les états unis le
canada rebond soir alexandre
effectivement il ya une liste d'autres
pays qui ont déjà mis en place des
quotas migratoires oui plusieurs pays
qui ont mis en place des quotas donc de
migrants économiques c'est un peu les
états unis qui on est bien inventer ce
système des quotas dès 1920 pour
recruter des travailleurs qu'ils ne
trouvaient pas sur le sol américain et
en 1990 les états unis lancent le permis
temporaire de travail le permis h 1b qui
est donnée à des travailleurs étrangers
très qualifiés avec un quota de à 85
mille visas par an et s'il ya trop de
demandes par rapport au quota et bien il
ya un tirage au sort des candidats qui
est effectué à noter qu'aux états unis
il ya également un quota de réfugiés
pouvant être accueillis chaque année et
ce quota il a été rehaussée par joe
biden à 60 2500 réfugiés par an alors
maintenant on va regarder le système
canadien ce qui se passe au canada en
2020 il y avait un quota de 341 milles
vos résidents permanents pouvant être
accueillis donc le canada est un pays
très ouvert à l'immigration économique
et c'est un système un peu particulier
car c'est un système à points qui a
d'ailleurs inspiré eric ciotti dans ses
propositions pendant la campagne des
républicains alors un système à points
donc pour être accueilli au canada faut
acquérir un certain nombre de points en
fonction de six critères les compétences
linguistiques le niveau d'études
l'expérience professionnelle avoir une
offre d'emploi l'âge ou encore la
capacité d'intégration c'est à dire si
on a déjà vécu au canada ou si on a un
proche qui vit dans ce pays est alors en
europe quels sont les pays qui ont mis
en place les quotas c'est bien si on
prend les données de 2019 il ya une
petite dizaine de pays européens qui ont
des quotas deux migrants économiques
alors des migrants économiques venant de
l'extérieur de l'union européenne bien
sûr donc c'est le cas dans des pays
comme l'espagne l'italie le portugal
l'autriche la bulgarie ou encore
l'estonie et les critères sont
différents selon les pays européens pour
définir ces quotas par exemple en
slovénie c'est le besoin de chaque
secteur économique qui permet de
calculer le coc tape en autriche ce côté
il est calculé en fonction de la
population active et puis en estonie le
calcul est fait en fonction du nombre de
résidents permanents qui sont déjà
arrivés sur le territoire national merci
alexandre pour pour toutes ces
informations jazz arabe si on parle
vraiment uniquement d'immigration
économique là est ce que ça peut être
finalement un système cohérent si je
prends le la logique canadienne d'une
sorte de quota de système à points oui
bien sûr toutes choses égales par
ailleurs chaque état étant souverain il
a le droit de choisir sur la question de
l'immigration légale de travail des
étudiants les personnes qui viennent sur
son sol moi je crois que c'est une
mesure qui est utilisé comme mesure
d'affichage politique parce que le sous
texte de la droite aujourd'hui c'est pas
celui ci une c'est l'idée d'aller vers
le rassemblement national et vers eric
zemmour c'est l'idée de dire que
l'immigration coûterait plus cher à kehl
à la france qu'elle ne rapporte or si
vous lisez le rapport de l'osce et 2
octobre 2021 il démontre que
premièrement ces personnes qui viennent
travailler ici souvent elles occupent
les emplois non qualifiés qu'une partie
des françaises et des français ne
souhaitent pas pour des raisons plus ou
moins légitimes mais ne souhaite pas
occupé et puis ensuite l'idée que la
france sur et seraient submergées sans
doute pas valérie pécresse mais le sous
texte du discours d'eric ciotti qui
parlent même d'ailleurs du grand
remplacement enfin pardon mais c'est
assez c'est assez équivoque donc du
point de vue politique pourquoi pas la
france a le droit de choisir qui vient
ou pas mais il me semble que les
motivations idéologiques ne sont pas
celles ci a c'est ça que je dénoncerai
titre vous allez répondre mais on écoute
eric ciotti d'abord sur ce thème sur ce
thème par sommes à un carrefour de
l'histoire où nous reprenons le cours de
notre destin en faisant tomber les
tabous du politiquement correct moi je
n'ai pas peur des mots si vous parlez il
faut parler de grand remplacement je
parle de remplacer ben a
transporté y est ce que vous est ce que
valérie précresse de remplacement non
non oui ça elle a dit non mais donc
c'était toute la wii mais je voudrais
que j'ai tout le monde non non non
elle a dit non je ne veux pas reprendre
ce terme au grand remplacement comme
michel barnier comme xavier bertrand
mais valérie pécresse à 10 mai mais
c'est vrai que il ay ay ay réalité a dit
oui mais il faut dire non oui pas non
mais attendez
c'est une réponse conçu et moi vous
n'avez pas à dire ce qu'elle doit dire
ou pas je suis désolé chacun sa place
moi je sais pas ce qu'il doit dire ou
pas quand elles apprécient ça c'est
qu'elle est présidente de la région ile
de france aujourd'hui
on a des zones il n'y a pas du grand
remplacement il ya un truc là où la
république est absente ou même certains
certains types de modes de vie
occidentaux sont absents et même ce qui
pose est ce que vous avez mode de vie
occidentaux madame parce que la vie
du tout je suis une femme d'ali j'ai une
fille la liberté des filles et des
femmes de s'habiller comme elles
venaient d'avoir un travail je suis
désolé quand à sevran vous avez dans un
café où ce qui est interdit aux femmes
ça pose des questions nos qualifs ça ce
sont les fameuses zones dans lesquelles
valérie pécresse voudrait créer une loi
différente puisqu'elle dit vous savez
pour les
ont nagé c'est le cas déjà c'est pas du
tout ce que je suis en train de dire
vous êtes en train de partir sur autre
chose non j'essaie de conduire andré
goerig je pense que la caricature c'est
pas un raisonnement si vous me permettez
après sur le fait encore une fois qu'il
n'est pas que des quotas sur
l'immigration il ya des choses qui
coûtent cher je prends un exemple encore
une fois local pardon en main de concret
de val d'oise on a aujourd'hui l'aide
sociale à l'enfance donc les
départements ils sont passés à de
quelques millions d'euros par an à 20
millions d'euros par an pour gérer la
question des mineurs dits isolé qui
viennent en fait avec des filières
mafieuses c'est un sujet sur lequel on
s'attaque dans un des articles justement
l'article 9 de la loi constitutionnelle
de valérie pécresse de son projet de loi
constitutionnelle parce que ça coûte
rien qu'au département du val d'oise 20
millions d'euros et donc solution vous
proposez c'est pas toutes les solutions
mais dans les solutions il ya par
exemple le fait que obligé à faire un
test osseux et que quand vous faites un
test ce contrairement à la loi hollande
aujourd'hui quand un mineur isolé refuse
de faire un test osseux il est présumé
mineur c'est incroyable quand même
beaucoup aujourd'hui on veut qu'il fasse
un test osseux pour qu'il soit présumé
s'il de refuse qu'ils soient refusés
présumé de nos mineurs quand vous avez
un type qui arrive avec une barre de
trois pieds de long blanche etc etc on
vous dit qu'il a 15 ans sur un garnement
valeur est d'ailleurs le vrai sort des
numéros
d'interdire le bureau de loisirs donc la
défenseur des droits elle est très
orienté
une autorité administrative on à la
commission nationale consultative des
droits de l'homme aussi rendu des avis
sur les tests au son des finances où les
tensions concernant les tests osseux
peuvent être provence est pas vrai et
dans ce cas si vous faites comment alors
c'est quoi toujours promis ne sont pas
toujours probants mais dans certains cas
sont extrêmement probant est en tous les
cas à partir d'une présomption de
minorité quand un mineur enfin un soi
disant mineures refuse le test c'est
quand même incroyable donc nous on part
sur la présomption contraire et cet
exemple parmi d'autres quand on dit
l'immigration temps de mardi aujourd'hui
en interne on sait qu'il marche ont eu
l'air de dire généralement à cause parce
que c'est vrai que quand on a 17 ans 17
ans et demi c'est difficile de savoir
exactement ce qui se passe est
aujourd'hui le mouvement il est plutôt
de dire prenant en compte la jeune
majorité justement pour éviter de 2 pour
ces six mois d'écart de même question
est complètement à la rue et de leur
maintenance est alors qu'il n'y a pas
que six mois des cas c'est pas que des
cas de six mois d'écart nous on a eu un
la police à la paf de menton des gens
qui avaient plus de 30 ans et nous
expliquer que c'était à cause de cette
présomption minorité que c'était des
mineurs enfin bon équateur y passer par
d'autres pays dans deux pays était
majeure c'est plus possible et quand je
vous dis que ça coûterait 20 millions au
département du val d'oise c'est qu'est
la place il ne s'occupe pas des enfants
qui sont en situation de l'enfance en
danger qui sont des leaders des sujets
au départ pour lesquels la zone doit se
doit travailler donc c'est une des vrais
sujets même sociaux mais l'idée
d'ailleurs c'est de mettre tout ça dans
la constitution parce que même les
quotas en réalité il pourrait être votée
ce en les plaçant la constitution et la
gageure à la pause de la jurisprudence
du conseil constitutionnel si on vous
allez me dire ali était d'agir
espérances du conseil constitue elle qui
était assez orienté après on peut penser
ce qu'on veut pour avoir un grand débat
droit constitionnel dure expérience
constitutionnel en tous les cas vous
savez que c'est un vrai frein et
qu'aujourd'hui ça se posent énormément à
la volonté du législateur qui n'est plus
très souverain donc c'est pour ça qu'on
veut faire une proposition de loi
constitutionnelle
mais si je peux me permettre
j'espère vous le prendrez pas mal mais
vous avez dit tout à l'heure que la
défenseure des droits n'était pas
indépendante vous venez de dire que le
conseil constitutionnel avait des
décisions mal orienté vous avez dit tout
à l'heure que l'agitateur n'était plus
souverain est-ce que vous n'êtes pas en
train de répéter la parole qu'on entend
en hongrie la parole qu'on entend en
pologne sur l'idée de dire qu'est
ce que vous venez de dire en dix minutes
moi je suis en phase qui suit un
observateur qui ne suis pas encarté
politiquement ap quand je vous écoute
j'entends un populisme judiciaire
on est en train de aujourd'hui de faire
croire aux français que c'est à cause de
lui
qui n'ont pu la maîtrise de leurs
frontières vous venez de dire que la
défenseure des droits et est orientée
que le conseil constitutionnel est
orienté n'avez vous pas l'impression que
c'est un peu facile d'expliquer aux
français que c'est à cause de l'état de
droit si c'est à cause de l'état de
droit qu'aujourd'hui les politiques sont
tenus moi je pars dont je fais partie
d'une génération qui a grandi à qui on a
appris que l'état de droit c'était bien
je fais un simplisme aujourd'hui il ya
une partie
notamment qui était vice-président de
votre famille eric ciotti il y à une
partie de la droite française je ne sais
pas si valérie pécresse a succombé à
cette idéologie là qui considère que
l'état de droit n'est plus la solution
mais le problème est quand je vous
entends je le regrette parce que la
droite de jacques chirac n'est pas la
droite qui critiquent l'état de droit on
m'a laissé une
question
c'est une insulte bon c'est insignifiant
du coup quand je parlais de la défenseur
des droits c'est un exemple très précis
d'un tele2 prime d'intégration il ya
d'autres mères d'ailleurs même de gauche
1 qui critiquent le prime du burkina là
on a deux preuves dans les îles de
loisirs de femmes qui se baignent un
burqini ce qui pose des problèmes de
sécurité même ce qu'on a expliqué au
défenseur des droits s'ils font un
malaise on aime les mêmes de sukkur
émettre des difficultés pour niçois pour
leur faire le massage cardiaque et en
plus des problèmes en plus d'ordre
public la défenseure des droits
critiqué très vivement valérie pécresse
et la même attaque et j'ai droit de
remettre en cause sa décision et de me
poser des questions a vu son parcours
politique sur sa neutralité
je suis désolé s'est pas vu sur la
personne bien sûr mais oui et c'est
toute une astuce au lieu des
constitutionnalistes acquis ce juriste
au défenseur des droits c'est pas madame
et dans tout ça j'aimerais de penser
bien sûr on sait que c'est assez orienté
g désolé mais en pensant aux anges après
le sens de la défense or justement quand
même oui mais la critique elle est
nourrie dans ce que vient d'arriver
nourrit aussi sur les tannants sur la
critique de l'état doit au delà de
l'exemple du burkina est ce qu
effectivement parce que c'est un une
question de positionnement politique de
la part de valérie pécresse qui est
quand même confronté à un eric ciott et
qui est puissant à une tentation de
l'union des droites enfin suspect un
vrai 5% oui mais janot boussouf est pas
comme si eric ciotti posait pas sûr sur
la toute nouvelle campagne de valérie
pécresse non mais attendez elle a fait
60 % on n'est pas le cas des verts 549
et ben oui parce qu'au produit 25 25 15
25 ans faches dernier un moment ce qui
ne veut pas dire qu'eric ciotti n'a pas
aussi toute sa place mais le mode pour
moi c'est le cas l insee valérie
pécresse est pas inutile fille avec
laquelle on a tout a été points
descendant qu'à chaque fois se fait
dicter sa politique parce qu'elle
penserait pas tout seul elle est
magistrate de formation elle connaît
bien ces sujets elle respecte l'état de
droit moi je vous permets fait dont je
vous ai pas dis ça je dis n'y at il pas
un lundi soir mais il n'était pas un sou
l'ex bien mais non il en est un dont on
vous dit que le conseil constitutionnel
rend des décisions orientez vous êtes en
train de dire que la plus haute
juridiction constitutionnelle et
ferrailles mieux possible en soit le
conseil constitutionnel leur virée de
31,2 jurisprudence je parle sous votre
contrôle par contre quand vous dites que
le conseil constitutionnel rendrait des
décisions politiques et donc elle sera
orientée ça c'est là quand même la haute
autorité des décisions vous avez dû
orienter m non bien sûr qu'on est bien
sûr bon laetitia que pas voulu
intervenir moi j'ai toujours aussi cette
perplexité quand je regarde le hiatus
entre les mots la volonté politique et
les actes notamment là c'était vraiment
très récent quand le gouvernement actuel
a essayé de jouer sur
les visas pour les ressortissants des
pays qui refuse ensuite de reprendre les
immigrés illégaux voyez on en est ou
face et dire qu'il ya un effet d'annoncé
ou on dit attention on va menacer le
maroc parce que c'est du maghreb qui
seul est concerné au premier chef et
finalement tout ça on est alors allez-y
la csn pense que je me suis moi même
pour être sincèrement méritait d'être
mise et comme trop bête on vient chez
vous dans ces émissions très documenté
de laisser passer consulaire contre des
visas parce qu'en fait pour les
téléspectateurs le problème c'est que
quand on doit expulser quelqu'un en
situation irrégulière il faut qu'ils
puissent passer par le consulat du pays
d'origine et donc il a laissé passer
consulaires et le psg ne peut refuser
d'état maintenant dit elle avait des
présidentielles si c'est ça pas de visa
on arrête visa pour vos ressortissants
ils n'ont pas été jusqu'au bout valérie
pécresse a elle dit carrément pas de
visa visage est à 100% eux ils disent 20
à 30% alors aujourd'hui ils ont eu
apparemment je crois un accord de la
tunisie et n'ont pas eu pour laisser
passer consulaire ils n'ont pas eu celui
de l'algérie et du maroc c'est pour
cette la mesure des robes de rétorsion
ça a été je crois 20 à 30% des visas
refusés mais pas la totalité il ya une
dimension intéressante il nous reste
quatre cinq minutes dans ce dans ce
débat tanière à chausser c'est ce qu'on
appelle l'étude d'impact d'une loi c'est
obligatoire en france depuis une dizaine
d'année 2009 10 à 2 de mémoire je
reviens à notre même si j'ai bien
compris que ça saint-céré à une
politique d'immigration global mais à la
question de des quotas migratoires
l'impact de cette loi est ce qu'on peut
l'évaluer combien il faudrait d'agents
je sais pas pour pour que ce soit
efficace qu'on puisse vraiment le mettre
en oeuvre effectivement c'est une autre
question
de cette dimension
d'évaluation comment elle est possible
chaque année devenir déterminé
effectivement ces quotas c'est un autre
aspect très concret très pragmatique
finalement mais qui est nécessaire
d'anticiper puisque puisque les quotas
serait certes encadré par la
constitution mais s'exprimerait ensuite
annuellement par la loi et je vous pose
la question parce que moi j'ai trouvé
que dans les débats valérie pécresse
était certainement celle qui finance à
inquiéter la plus précise sur le
financement de ces mesures et c'est donc
là ont le cuir en l'occurrence est ce
que vous avez évalué ce que ça suppose
en termes de de puissance publique pour
faire respecter ses quotas d'immigration
combien d'agents supplémentaires pour
que ça fonctionne ce que je veux dire
pas pour ça d'ailleurs elle a aussi tout
une réforme du droit d'asile heures non
pas pour lutter contre le droit d'asile
gd entre guillemets légal c'est pour
tous les déboutés du droit d'asile qui
ne partent pas et on en retrouve aussi
dans l'embryon chez eux et pour moi
c'est un drame social que vous avez des
gens qui depuis 30 ans juin des cages à
poules c'est moi qui avais pas le
passage progrès donc pour tout cela en
effet il fout du monde et en même temps
on a mammouth parfois même territoriales
qui fait que les thèmes voir détails du
budget de la france de la note est de
tête et c'est donc est la part du
principe que il faut supprimer des
postes d'agents ou de fonctionnaires
c'est plus compliqué que ça dans des
millefeuilles là on a rajouté alors que
ce n'était pas utile quand on dit supris
mais attention c'est pas jeter des gens
dehors c'est atteindre aussi les départs
à la retraite si le départ etc et en
même temps comme dirait l'autre elle a
concrètement c'est remettre plusieurs
dizaines de milliers d'emplois dans la
fonction publique dans ce type d'
administration ou dans celle des
magistrats parce que là on est ça
concerne aussi les magistrats 2d pour d
ordre administratif
au sein de la police et puis elle avait
aussi proposé d'ailleurs pour les
soignants pour elle était au bout de ce
qu'elle avait dit mais c'est vrai que
chez d'autres candidats on n'est pas
allé sur comment on récupère de l'argent
concrètement je vous propose d'écouter à
dernier extrait de la conférence de
presse des manuels macron parce qu'on
est vraiment au coeur de notre de notre
débat puisqu'il évoque la lah les flux
migratoires et la politique de nos
voisins britanniques qui ne sont plus
dans l'union mais avec lesquels il faut
bien s'entendre parce qu'il n'y a pas de
filière légale d'instruction du droit
d'asile fait part des britanniques parce
qu'il ya toujours un système qui existe
depuis les années 80 opaque où le modèle
économique britannique repose sur le
travail illégal d'étrangers si ces
situations ne sont pas réglés par les
britanniques de bonne foi nous aurons
toujours ces situations à nos frontières
ou la france à la bonne volonté de tenir
ce point de passage la réponse elle est
dans la coopération britannique comme on
dirait chez vous vous êtes de chez nous
maintenant devrais je dire be my guest
que les britanniques seraient en gage de
bonne foi sur ce sujet
dernière chose c'est intéressant parce
que quand on parle de politique
migratoire il faut jamais oublier la
dimension européenne la dimension de
schengen bien sûr un schengen c'est la
création d'un espace on peut librement
circuler où toutes les personnes
circulent librement donc sans frontières
mais schengen s'est accompagnée dès le
début de mesures compensatoires
c'est-à-dire de renforcement à toutes
les frontières extérieures et donc celle
agence frontex
c'est la lutte contre la criminalité aux
frontières et donc donc effectivement
c'est un point de vue intéressant alors
sur le royaume uni ça a toujours été
particulier puisque le royaume uni n'a
jamais été dans schengen donc sa sortie
de l'union européenne ne change pas
grand-chose sur sur le terrain et sont
des accords spécifiques
franco-britannique qui règle qui déplace
en fait la frontière britannique en
france avec évidemment des contreparties
pour nous quand même mais qui pose des
vraies difficultés est-ce que florence
portée il faut pas aussi beaucoup de
édité sur une thématique comme celle là
parce qu'on parle de calais par exemple
ça fait ça fait deux trois décennies
finalement la visibilité puis a pas que
ça et aussi pourquoi il ya des gens qui
viennent sincèrement pour profiter entre
guillemets du cem vous avez aussi des
gens qui viennent tout simplement parce
que ce qu'ils vivent dans leur pays
c'est hyper compliqué moi c'est pas
forcément des pays en guerre mais avec
le réchauffement climatique déjà vous
est d'avoir une vibration là ce qu'on
connaît actuellement c'est rien par
rapport à ce qu'on risque de connaître
et il ne suffit pas de dire on redevient
souverains chez nous ce qui pour moi
chez audi est important il va falloir
aussi avoir une direction forte sur
l'aide au développement